the first thing that was on the cards
was set it up put it into auxiliary
angle
okay so they've actually prescribed for
you the form that you've got to use
what do you notice alpha okay so the
easy way to go is to say well look
i'll just do the expansion i'll just do
the expansion if you got confused
because you were trying to do it
automatically or by formula
go back to the expansion let's go back
it makes it a lot easier okay so you get
your r out the front
side a cos b
minus cos a
sine b okay so you set that up
you compare your coefficients you set up
your tan etc get r
and here's where you end up that just
this component
one on root three
you should have ended up here two over
root three was your amplitude
and pi on three was the phase shift
okay so that's where you were going for
two marks the first mark was really just
to
sift out all of your coefficients and
your second mark was actually to arrive
okay then part two now
this was a bit mean of them to not give
you the result because a handful of
people
did muck up part one and then if you
used it for part
two and three which was a smart way to
go then you ended up in a bit of a twist
okay but you can actually do it
just from the forms the equations they
give it to you and not use auxiliary
angle forms okay
so if you start with this right then you
do x dot
and you get your solution out and then
you do x double dot
okay now there's an important step here
i'm going to point out you get to this
oops
okay then when you get to here you know
what you have to prove
so you cannot simply go from here to x
minus four you can't do it
okay you have to show where the four
is in here so you gotta add it and then
you gotta take it away and that's a
crucial line
okay so the line that was being expected
was this
okay now it's clear now it's clear
because you can see
there's x right there
okay so if you ask the show you must
make x
obvious you can't expect to do any
manipulation to get there okay so
there's your
simple harmonic differential equation
okay done now when you move on to part
three
ah it was so simple it was so simple it
was kind of a um
it's kind of a giveaway two marks
by far the simplest way was to say okay
well look i've already worked out what x
dot is
like i worked that out in the previous
part okay um
if you use the auxiliary angle for it
makes it even easier
because you get this if this is what
you're working off okay
you're going to get x dot b equal to
this
okay there's your x dot now here's the
thing forget about the coefficient for a
second
right forget about the coefficient if
this is x dot and this is all you saw
right when is the maximum velocity
maximum speed achieved
right what's the fastest this thing can
possibly go
and the answer is one right because
that's the it goes from one to negative
one to one that's
that's all you can do so actually i
don't really care about this guy right
all i need to solve is this being equal
to one
okay so you go cos four t minus pi on
three
equals one you want the first time
the first time is when that angle is
equal to zero
four t minus pi on three equals zero
and the pi on twelve falls out just like
that
oops seconds
okay